Okay, but if you want to pass arguments to a car, so
if you want to specify if you want instantiate and let's let's see
how we can instantiate a class. I'm going to collapse this code.
If you want to instantiate a car.
You would have you would first type in a variable.
The name of variable. So for example, you know
Tesla.
Or the Model S.
and
assign this to car
and then this is not calling a function rather your constructing
a class your instantiating the class. So this is now called an instance.
This is an object now and it is now an instance of the class car.
now
the model S has certain
Characteristics there are some things that are specific to a Model
S. So here let's say we have a Honda Civic.
Both of these are cars, but they're not the same car.
There are things that distinguish them apart from each other.
So a Model S for example belongs to the company
Tesla.
And a Civic belongs to Honda.
This could be a black car.
This could be a red car.
this could have
a price
I don't know how much it goes for.
Maybe $300,000. I don't know.
And this one, you know is more economical. Let's say I don't know 60.
Okay, so these are the arguments.
Of the for the class. However, you're not
passing these.
These would you would not open the you would not indicate the
parameters in here.
If you want to receive these arguments.
Then you would there's a special method.
Called Thunder in it. Why is it called Dunder in
it?
You'll see now.
It's called Dunder because it has double underscores.
And it's fast. It's say thunder in it. That's a
double underscore in it.
So if you want to accept arguments.
And if you want to declare the parameters for this class, you would
do it inside this method.
So you have the brand of the car the color of
the car the price of the car?
And one thing you need to know, is that whatever you create a class.
method
he there's one parameter. You must always put at
the beginning.
You can have as many parameters as you want for any of your methods, but
there's one parameter that was always go at the beginning and that is the self
method.
And it has to be called that.
So it has to be called self and it must go the beginning.
And even if a method doesn't accept any parameters,
it must still have self.
So you would self in here self in here self in here,
but why do we do this? Why do we?
Why do we?
include self
Well again.
this class
has four
methods and three variables
the reason they are put inside.
The same class is because they are meant to
work with each other.
And they're supposed to be able to read the variables inside the
class.
so, how would
how would if you want to if the car is meant to let's
say break?
That means they must accelerate to zero, right?
To break a car means to bring the speed of the car to
zero.
That means brake must have access to the accelerate method.
So if you type in accelerate.
Just like that and pass in the argument zero. So let's
say the accelerate method will take to arguments self is
mandatory. It has to go to the beginning but the second argument is speed.
Okay.
when you type a function
this implies that the function is global meaning python
will think you have a function out here.
called
accelerate
And you can actually do this you can have.
They will not contribute they will be no conflict. They
can have a function.
And a class method with the same name in the same file, and
that's not going to cause any problems. Maybe you'll get confused but positive
will have no issues.
but either way when you
type an accelerate as a function python will
think
There's a function outside the class, which is not
the case.
So what we do is we would type in self dot accelerate.
All right, so that's why we have to put self
as a parameter of every single method.
And even in the internet method if you wanted to change these any
of this information.
Okay, so properties shouldn't be shouldn't have
any values initially.
Okay.
We don't want a hard code the properties of a car. We want to
do it after we instantiate the class. So if you want to change
the color of the car.
Then you would say self.
dot color
equals to and I'm just going to rename these
so you can tell them apart.
This this will be parameter.
So the values for these parameters will come.
From outside the class so self color would be
color parameter.
and for example self Dot
brand
Would be brand parameter.
Okay.
So this is where you receive arguments of a class.
Not up there.
Okay.
So and I'm going to come and we're gonna
come to class. We're gonna return the list in a moment. But if
you want to watch this now, this is this is this this is
what dot syntax is about
Okay.
If you want to access a property of
a class or a method of a class.
Remember we said property is a variable.
Of a class method is a function of a class if
you want to access a property or a method you
must use the DOT.
Now you can of course do it this way.
You can you can do it that way as well.
Okay, but
the
more common convention is to use the dots attacks.
Okay.
so if you wanted to
down here
after we instantiate the class.
Call a method.
Who of a car so we know that cars can accelerate right?
How would you do it? You would say model.
as dot accelerate
And this is the point I was trying to make by.
Talking so much about classes.
Whenever you see a DOT.
You should know that whatever proceeds it.
Is always an object.
Anytime you see a DOT whatever proceeds it.
is an object
another way to visualize Model S.
Is the keyword dictionary?
So we say dictionaries and objects, right? It has a method called accelerate.
Which is a function.
It has a method called Break.
Which is also a function.
Just be something consistent here.
it has
properties like price
What did we say that price is equal to 3300 k?
It has a color which is a property.
Okay.
So if you want to access any of these.
If you want to access the values of any of these elements when
it comes to objects, it's more common to use dots
and tax.
When you create a class and then you instantiated
you end up with this object.
And when you access an element, if you want to access the element of any object
to use dots attacks.